recovery efforts still underway in six
states after a string of deadly
tornadoes ripped through the heartland
left a trail of massive devastation in
kentucky at least 74 people are
confirmed dead but liberals are
hell-bent on using this strategy to push
their climate change agenda
all that i know is that
the intensity of the weather across the
board
has some impacts as a consequence of the
warming of the planet
and the climate change this is going to
be our new normal you need to pass build
back better because that that bill has
climate provisions that will address
this problem at its you know at its core
which is the
warming of the planet
no scientific studies have yet shown any
direct link between climate change and
tornadoes and look at this graph that
shows how global weather related deaths
have actually fallen dramatically over
decades greg that's bjorn lumborg yeah
yeah from a great piece and uh it's
actually government data but
bjorn lumberg had published a great
piece in the wall street journal that
shows that we are far safer from climate
disasters and this is when there's more
stuff to damage right than decades ago
as the population grows you have a rise
in all kinds of structures that are in
the paths of floods and hurricanes and
tornadoes but the trend of weather
related damage in the last 30 years has
gone from a 0.26 gdp global gdp to 0.18
so it's actually going down but this
happens all the time whenever there's a
a tragedy like this you have people who
don't know anything about climate who
say these things and then we have to go
and we got to look for the data and then
we have to come on the show we have to
do a really
long segment about climate because we
feel compelled to like because you have
to spend half the time calling these
idiots out like michael mann saying that
there's been more deaths from climate
disasters than covet death there are 21
500 climate related deaths right in one
year compared to something like it's
almost 18 million right now at this
point globally
yeah the excess death yeah so that's an
840 times difference
and michael mann is lying bald-faced
lying on tv saying that that that's not
the case so this is something that we
have to do every time we have to do the
legwork every time to combat these
fallacies when in fact they would if
only they did this about crime whether
you can actually see the direct links
between you know no cash bail right and
the revolving door and pre you have the
but they won't do that cause and effect
but they fabricate a cause and effect
because there's no solution to it which
maintains their power
and dana the pouncing on this before
they even they're how many 100 people
still missing roughly before the dead or
even found the pouncing on this is just
so you might remember right near the
surface remember when the surfside condo
collapsed
secretary granholm at the department of
energy the first thing she said is she
blamed it on climate change and that
wasn't what it was right so that they
just immediately jump on it and then
immediately they don't take scientific
data or evidence to link something to
their policies they just automatically
say that okay the tornado strengthens
our case for the build back better
because there's climate change positions
in there inflation strengthens their
case for buildback better everything the
jets losing every sunday is a
justification for a build back better
yeah more money and more control that's
all they want jesse regard like half a
trillion dollars is somehow giving it to
michael mann who doesn't even know how
many deaths there are from covid that's
who they that's that's who would make
decisions with the money essentially
well but that's the game they play so
the government goes out and they say we
got four million dollars to study the
link between tornado ferocity and
capitalism and some 50 000 a year
researcher at a state school says i'll
take 4 million hey i'll do that study
i'll give you what you want so he does
the study and then the government holds
up the study and says science see
let me raise your taxes now
we
have had tornadoes forever
even before geraldo all right
that's old they're very old all right do
you think the native americans were
studying
tornado varas ferocity do you think the
settlers
in in in tennessee that we're studying
tornadoes we're going to go
in 1973 that was the first time we came
up with a system to study tornado
philosophy you know how we did it all we
do we calculate the speed of the wind
versus how much devastation there is on
the ground but it depends on the path of
the tornado whatever's on the ground is
going to be devastating and whenever you
build something it's going to be
sturdier as civilization advances as
bjorn gutfeld mentioned thank you so
they come up with this idea uh the
world's been around for fifth what five
billion years so we're just going to
take the last 50 years and say you know
what it's our fault it's capitalism's
fault so we're just going to give all
your taxpayer dollars to green donors
and then the green donors are going to
re-engineer the entire world economy
in a way that doesn't use fossil fuels
that is so stupid it's like a pagan
ritual remember oh it's the wind gods
are angry
we have to sacrifice a virgin so the
wind gods aren't angry at us that's how
much sense this makes rob marciano of
abc my favorite non-janistine fox
weather person said there are no studies
linking the severity of tornadoes to
climate change and to his credit the
president of the united states joe biden
said we can't say with absolute
certainty that tornado was because of
climate change as a matter of fact some
of it has to do with el nino so there's
a little reason from the white house
we have to acknowledge
that poor little boy yes he was such a
sweet kid yes so we get we get a little
sliver or soups on or teaspoon of
empathy yeah no we we
were just grateful he said he
conditioned a phrase
we'll take anything at this point